okay i think we should
get started so in terms of time benedict
we're aiming for
40 minutes um
and again this is uh recorded as
it says met up top and we're going
youtube
um yeah so let's get started thank you
benedict for being here
and please go ahead
okay yeah thanks ellie um and thanks
everyone for coming
i'll talk about uh proofs for
in a pairing product and applications
and this is work that we actually
started
while doing the simon's workshop so this
is
a direct result of this and it's uh
joint work with uh mary
pratosh nirvan and psy and
we just updated the paper online so even
if you have
had a look at it i encourage you to
download
the new version which has a lot more
evaluation and and
i i think it's better written and you
should definitely
go check it out so what is an inner
pairing
product um what or what are we
constructing well we're constructing
proofs
efficient algebraic proofs for these
bilinear languages
so very generally at a very high level
we're going to prove statements like
there exists vectors
a and b of group elements in by linear
groups
and such that some public value t
is the product of the pairings of
each of the individual elements and
things that we achieve are that we have
a very
efficient brewer um it uses
n pairings roughly or on the order of n
pairings
and and the efficient proof will
actually be a big
highlight because a lot of the things
that we achieve you could
previously only achieve with recursive
composition
and there this this recursive
composition of snarks
requires very expensive np reductions so
um there the cost would be uh maybe only
you know you have
the the the np reduction has a blow up
maybe of the
factor of a thousand or something along
those lines and you can see that in
our evaluations and then we also have
very succinct proofs so our
proofs are a logarithmic number of
elements and
we want the verifier we achieve that the
verifier is also going to be
efficient and we'll have
we we use many different uh protocols
but they're all
the instantiations of one generalized uh
protocol and we we are one generalized
argument system
and which we then optimize for different
implementations and
one of our contributions is this
generalized argument system
for which we can present one security
proof and then you can instantiate it in
many different ways
and get immediately get
secure protocols out of it with
different properties
so i first want to talk about a couple
of the applications that we have
so one of the first and main
applications that our protocol
has is a polynomial commitment scheme so
in a polynomial commitment scheme
you commit to a degree d polynomial
using a
short commitment and then the approver
can
can convince the verifier that the
polynomial evaluated at a point
z has some particular value and that the
degree of the polynomial
is bounded and
these polynomial commitments have
received a lot of excitement in
in the last i would say one or two years
um and mainly this is because you can
actually build
full-fledged snarks for mp um
using these polynomial commitments and
for the most part the
efficiency properties of the polynomial
commitment
dictate the efficiency properties of the
snark so if you have a very efficient
polynomial commitment or whatever
cryptographic properties or whatever
efficiency properties your polynomial
commitment
has this these are almost directly going
to be the efficiency properties of your
snark for np and also you can use
polynomial commitments to build
accumulators and vector commitments and
so they're very
useful tool so the particular polynomial
commitment that we built
um has a couple
really nice properties main in that
so here's a comparison to the probably
most widely used polynomial commitment
scheme which is called the kzg
polynomial commitment scheme
and the key areas in which our
commitment scheme shines is that it has
a much smaller reference string
so the reference string is only
asymptotically only square root in the
degree of the polynomial
and the evaluation prover
also only uses square root of the
cryptographic operations
so of course the the evaluation prover
has to evaluate the pro
polynomial but it in addition to that it
only
performs uh square root of the um
kind of cryptographic operations and you
can see this translate in our
implementation
so at a very large for a very large
degree
two to the 26 polynomial i think this is
like 200 uh well now i'm
getting my exponent um the
you can see that the crs size is only
four megabytes
versus in the kzg commitment scheme the
crs size is
uh would be 3.2 gigabytes and the
evaluation prover
takes 15 seconds versus 60 minutes
and especially the cs size is something
that is actually
very much a constraint in practice we've
we've talked to for example
filecoin and they want to create these
proofs for gigantic statements and they
have the problem that if you have a very
large cs then
this has to get sent around the the
network to all the different provers who
want to use it
and so this is actually very a practical
constraint
and what are the trade-offs well the
traders are that our
um proofs are a little bit or they're
larger they are
um the kcg proofs are constant size only
380 bytes
and for us this is on the order of less
than say four kilobytes
and the verifier time is also um
a little bit larger so 46 milliseconds
versus five milliseconds
but there are certainly applications
where you know the
the verifier time and the proof size are
not the bottlenecks anymore
but the the prover and the cr size
become the bottlenecks
and then this polynomial commitment
scheme might be a good application for
that
the second application is related to
something called
roll up so roll up is a concept that is
now also widely used in the blockchain
space so
traditionally you have
if you have a bunch of blockchain users
who all have transactions
well then they post all of this
transaction on the blockchain and
every single miner every single
verifier in in the blockchain consensus
system
has to verify all of the transactions
and the idea of rollup is to introduce a
so-called rollup server
which collects all of the transactions
and then creates verifies all of them
and creates a short proof short snark
that all the transactions are valid and
then the
rollup server sends a summary of the
transactions
and the short proof to the miners
and the miners just verify this proof
and
it turns out that verifying the proof is
significantly
uh more efficient than verifying say
tens of thousands of transactions and so
this is a
an efficiency gain that is achieved here
using this roll-up
but sometimes you want to have
you want to have also roll-up with
privacy so you want to have transactions
that themselves reveal
no information or have less information
about how much
money a person is transacting to another
person so the way to achieve privacy i
won't go
into any details of how this works but
is to use
also zk snarks at the transaction level
so every single transaction now has a zk
snark
asserting that whatever
state updates this or whatever local
state update the transaction does
is in fact valid with respect to say
some commitment to the state
and if these commitments are hiding um
then the snark then then uh
there's no privacy leak the details of
the transactions
don't have to get revealed but now the
problem
problem is that the rob server has to
actually provide a proof that it still
has to verify the transactions and
provide a proof but
that it did this correctly but the
problem is now that verifying
transactions
actually involves checking snugs
themselves
so what we would need is a way sort of a
classical way to achieve this is by
using recursive snarks
so the roll-up server would produce a
snark
that asserts that all of the transaction
snarks
are in fact valid and what we want
is kind of a way to or in more general
what we would like to do is
have a way that we can just aggregate
all of the transaction snarks into a
single small
and we in fact achieve that
so we build a protocol for aggregating
snarks
that does not use recursion so
we you can combine many snarks into a
short proof and
in particular this isn't a generic
protocol that works for any snark
um this works in particular for
pairing-based snarks like
graph 16 and previously
as i said this was only known from one
level recursion
and the the key benefit here
is that our aggregation protocol is
completely algebraic
so it doesn't rely again it doesn't rely
on these very expensive np reductions
and you can see this in the fact that
say i want to aggregate 60 for snarks
then
our approach takes the aggregation
procedure takes 1.1
seconds versus with one level recursion
uh it requires 18 minutes and 256
gigabytes of memory
and the the the um the large memory
comes from having to compute a very
large fft here
so it seems somewhat inherent that
that you need that much memory and after
that after 64. so this is a 900x
speedup and after 64 proves
the the one level recursion approach
unfortunately runs out of our machine
ran out of memory we didn't
have a big enough machine but
we ran our aggregation protocol further
and we can see that in less time so in
12 minutes
we can aggregate uh 65 000 proofs so a
thousand times more proofs
in in less time so um
yeah so this shows you the the very
concrete efficiency gains
from using the protocol
we further extended the pro the the
protocol
to enable
low memory proofs low memory snarks for
machines
so say you have a machine that that
takes
t steps of complexity c
and you wanted to prove that the machine
evaluated correctly i did the
computation of t steps
correctly and if you naively do a
monolithic proof
then this takes o tilde of
c times t space
so it takes quite a lot of space
and our approach is that you simply
create t
snarks each asserting a single
transition
and then you use the inner pairing
product to aggregate all of these snarks
and we can take advantage of the
structure of the
of this computation so that the input of
one computation or the output of one
computation step is the input of the
next computation step such that the
verifier
is going to be logarithmic in the number
of steps
so the verifier is succinct this is very
efficient
and the space that is used is only um
c plus t so it's o of t because you need
to store
all the intermediate proofs one for each
step but
it's not the product of c times t
because you don't need to keep the
entire internal state of the machine
um around because at every at every step
you compress it using
an individual snark and
with recursive stark or you can actually
get
something even better so you can get ofc
space but recursive snarks as
we've seen in the previous application
they have the
the downside of often having very large
constants
so it's again it's an it's an
application where we get something not
quite as good asymptotically as the best
known solution
but something that is uh likely to be
much more practical
or has much better constants
[Music]
and as the final application
we can
the final application is related to bls
signature aggregation
so just to quickly recall if i have a
signature aggregation means that i have
n signatures from n different public
keys
on n different messages and there is a
public aggregation protocol which anyone
can run
to create a single short signature and
verifying the single short signature
convinces the verifier that all of the
[Music]
that the users i3n signed the statements
m1 through mn but the problem with
dls signature aggregation is that
the verification still requires
one pairing per aggregated signature so
you still need to do
n expensive pairings or
so they're not extremely expensive but
you know there's there's somewhat
expensive and we would like to reduce
this car
the the costs of these n pairings and
this is exactly our fourth application
we have a protocol for outsourcing
pairings
so it's a protocol where say you want to
do
the the some verifier has to do and
pairings
it can outsource that computation very
efficiently to approver
and then the verifier still does linear
work
but it only does two n exponentiations
and uh exponentiations are generally uh
cheaper and you can use
multi-exponentiation it's really a
multi-exponentiation of size to n
and um you can outsource this using a
log n size proof
and concretely this gives you about an
8x
speed up at n equals 2 to the 20
and one nice property is that
at least the interactive version of this
this protocol
is actually a statistically sound proof
so how do we achieve all of this well
the main protocol that we base our
base our inner pairing product on is
the inner product argument from brutal
at all that is also used in
or this particular variant is from
bulletproofs and in the inner product
argument
you have some you have a commitment
to two vectors in the scalar so this
commitment
the commitment function here is denoted
by h
and uh in particular it's a it's a
patterson commitment
so you commit to the so a
and b are elements in
um a prime field and you commit to them
using
this patterson commitment and the inner
product of a and b
and bulletproofs at a very high level
works by reducing the statement of seism
about vectors a and b so to a statement
of size n over two so you have a one
round
interactive interaction with a verifier
in which the prover sends two
commitments
and the verifier sends one challenge and
after that
you reduce the statement to
a state about the vectors a prime and b
prime and these vectors are now
of half the size and you can run the
protocol for a logarithmic number of
rounds and in the
end you have to do one evaluation of h
on a constant statement
and the total communication is only
two login commitments so one two
commitments per round and log and round
and the verify work is linear still in
the original statement
but all of the work it turns out and
this will become important later
is in computing the final commitment key
so what we looked at is whether we can
use the same structure of argument for
other protocols so not just for this
kind of inner product argument where you
commit to
field element vectors but what are the
properties of age here that are
important to apply this or
how can we apply the same structure of
argument to
other to get other protocols
and the
key insight is that the that
h so we wanted to abstract the
properties of
age used in the inner product argument
and
one key insight is that h is homomorphic
in both the
commitment key and in the messages so we
can say that h is a doubly homomorphic
function
so to see this we have
g to the a is times g to the b is the
same as g to the a plus b
i'm using this this vectorized notation
here
and we can see that so g and h are the
the commitment keys and
a and b are the messages so the first
um equation here is that it's uh
uh linear in the it's linear in the the
message space and it's also linear in
the commitment key space so g and h are
the commitments
keys and it turns out that
if we um that we can build
use a similar protocol for other doubly
homomorphic commitments
and in particular we call these inner
product commitments
so for an inner product commitment age
we have three prime order groups
m1 m2 and 3 and we have some bilinear
map
between m1 m2 and m3 so
in the inner product argument
m1 and m2 are both just a prime field
and the by linear map is just
multiplication
or m1 m3 2 and m3 are actually the
just the prime field and
the bilinear map is just the
multiplication in that field
but uh it turns out that we can
generalize the protocol
to use more more general by linear maps
it doesn't actually we don't really need
that many properties or
the only property that we need is that
the map is bilinear
and we can also apply this to
more general primordial groups
and what our commitment h provides
it's binding
to angular c
so a is a and b are size m vectors
and c is a scalar and then
the protocol that we provide this
generalization or this generalized inner
product argument
jeeper is the proof that
c is the inner product between a and b
and it's jeeper has exactly the same or
it uses exactly
as the argument just using this
generalization
and the subtraction of h
and we prove that or
we first prove that g power is secure um
by saying that the interactive variant
of jeeper
is a proof of knowledge for this
relation here
that i just said so that a you have a
commitment to
a b and a scalar and that the scalar is
the inner product between a and b
and we prove that it's a proof of
knowledge for this relation
or extracting a break of the binding
property of age
and because if we assume that h is a
binding commitment
well then we can prove that gpa is an
argument of knowledge for
the relation or jeepa that is
parameterized
by h
but in practice most of the applications
actually require non-interactive and so
this protocol
uh the security proof is is uh
it's very similar to the security proof
for the inner product argument
but it the one of the nice properties is
that it really generalizes about for all
of these protocols
and we can now just come up with a new
hash function with a new inner product
commitment h
and as long as we can show that it's
binding or
we can assume that it's binding well
then we know that then we immediately
have a protocol for it
a g variant for it and we immediately
know that
it's secured by ethereum one
but one problem is that most
applications of
uh our protocols and in general also
for bullet proofs and and other
protocols based on the inner prior
argument require non-interactive
arguments
and the way that we get a
non-interactive argument is we apply the
fear-trimmier transform
to so jeeper is a public coin protocol
so we can apply the fiat mirror
transform
which gives us a non-interactive
protocol
the one problem with that is that if we
naively apply
the fiachemia transform to
a logarithmic round protocol like gpa
this gives us
a superpolynomial extractor so the
the um extractor then runs into time
poly lambda to the log lambda
and um so this
is i mean this is
at least this is not what we would like
we would like to have a polynomial time
extractor and so we
at least somewhat um
alleviate these concerns by showing that
if we treat treat age as an
algebraic commitment so we um
look at age in in an algebraic group
model
or in kind of what we call it an
algebraic commitment
model then the fiat scheme transform of
gpa
is a non-interactive argument of
knowledge so in the random it's a
non-interactive argument of knowledge
in the random oracle model given that h
is abundant commitment
and in the proof extracting
because we're in this algebraic
commitment model
extracting a b and c is
trivial this is immediately given to us
by this idealized model
but then the difficulty comes in showing
that c
is in fact the inner product between a
and b and we
rely on a zero finding game that
which bounds the probability that
if i if an adversary comes up with a
polynomial and then commits to that
polynomial
and we generate a challenge from the
commitment of the polynomial
then it's um
something here was missing then it's
unlikely that the polynomial at this
this random point or this point
generated by the random oracle
is zero unless the polynomial itself is
zero
um so we have uh we from this this prior
paper we have a very concrete bound on
what that probability is and using uh
this bound we can actually prove our
theorem too
or we apply this multiple times at every
round
so yeah so the nice thing of theorem two
is that it applies to all gpa protocols
so for example it also applies to
bulletproofs and and other
instantiations
like lmr19 and other instantiations
that have this similar structure
and that we're previously only proven
secure and then
they're interactive variants
[Music]
so now how can we instantiate gpen
um well we can use the
patterson commitment which gives us the
bulletproof variant
we can also instantiate it using
the the afgho commitment which is a
commitment to
group elements and is used by linear
groups so this gives us kind of our this
is
what we're mostly using through the
paper this gives us the inner pairing
product
and this variant uh has also been used
previously by lmr19 for it to also
produce proofs on group elements and
the most direct instantiation of it has
a communication of six log n target
group elements
and and it still has linear verification
time and we'll get to
uh getting around the last fact in in a
second
and interestingly it sometimes even
makes sense to commit
to to use the identity commandment
so the commitment to a and b would then
just be literally
the vectors a and b and the inner
product and this can be useful
or using jeeper in that way can be
useful
if computing the inner product or
evaluating the bilinear map
um is expensive itself and this is
exactly what we're the this protocol is
exactly what we're using
for outsourcing pairings
so now we want to
so we have this this um
nice protocol now for for these pairing
arguments
and there's been even prior work on
exactly that by lmr19
but this protocol still has this linear
verification time
and the it turns out that the expensive
cost in uh for the verifier in jeeper
is computing the final commitment key
and so
in every round you have to update your
commitment key and in the end you have a
final commitment key
and it turns out that
so if we look at if let um
l x 1 through x log n be
the be the
challenges that are generated in each
round so x1 is the first one challenge
and x log n is the
last one challenge and g is the original
commitment key
so it's a it's a vector of size n
then the polynomial p of y
is um which has this form
and is a degree n polynomial it turns
out that the final commitment key
g final is exactly a
commitment to the coefficients of p
and this is an observation that was done
by
uh boy griggs and hotwood uh in in the
halo paper
and the interesting thing is that
if you look closely at this polynomial p
of y
so it's a degree n polynomial and if you
expand it
it has n different coefficients
but so computing g to the p is actually
takes time of n but
p of y can be efficiently evaluated so
evaluating it at any point z
only takes uh time o of log n
so this can be evaluated in time of
log okay writing with a mousepad is not
very efficient but um
so we are going to take advantage of
exactly this fact
so the idea that we have is we want to
outsource the computation
of g final to the prover right and and
here up here we have
exactly the the structure of g final and
what we're going to do is we're going to
use a structured reference string
so for a secret value s the
reference string is g to the monomials
of s
and in a bilinear group and then it
turns out that
g final is a kzg polynomial commitment
to this polynomial p of y
so um if you're not familiar with kcg
you have to trust me
on this but you can see that it's
g final is equal to p
evaluated at s and this is exactly the
the uh the structure of the kzg
polynomial commitment scheme
and then the protocol is going to be
that the prover sends g final or its
claim of g
final to the verifier the verifier will
sample
a random challenge z and the prover will
convince the verifier that the
polynomial inside g
final evaluated at z is exactly equal to
p of z
and it's important that the verifier
can themselves
compute p of z right this is a very
this this computation itself is
efficient so
it then the pruvit then provides this
kzg
proof to show that g final has exactly
the right structure
and given that the verifier can accept
g-funnel
and use it in the tip protocol
so there's some important details of
course missing here
and you can see the the paper for um
to find them so
the summary is that clip is secured
security is based on the security of
jeeper
and uh instantiated with the correct
uh in our product commitment
and the security of kzg and it uses this
this
uh structured updateable reference
string
so it is a trusted setup um but one that
is updatable
and the important property is now that
the
verifier doesn't have to do linear work
anymore
because the one expensive computation
step
we've outsourced to uh the
the approver so the verifier only
performs six pairings
and six log n exponentiation in gt
and we use multiple variants of tip
and for example sometimes you don't
want to commit to two vectors of group
elements but just one vector of group
elements
and have an inner product with say a
public vector of values and so on and so
forth
and for that we use um we have a two log
n
so in some of these variants we have
even shorter proofs but
the nice thing again using g plus it's
very simple to instantiate all of these
different protocols
all of these different variants and
immediately have security proofs for
them
so now and this is
[Music]
yeah so now we can use tip to
construct a polynomial commitment so
say we have um a bivariate polynomial
commitment
so p of x comma y is degree n and x and
degree
m and y and it turns out that if you
have a univariate polynomial
you can easily transform it into a
bivariate polynomial
where n and m are about square root of b
and the we're using
the graph 11 two-tiered
commitment scheme which writes
it basically the first step is to write
our
um so growth 11's commitment scheme is a
commitment scheme for matrices
and we can write our coefficients as a
matrix
a so this is an m by n matrix a
and each entry is one of the
coefficients of the polynomial p
and then we commit to each row using a
patterson commitment
and then commit to the row commitments
right so these are now
group elements using the afghan
commitment
and so this is using a pairing product
and
note that the final commitment to this
matrix is still doubly homomorphic
and if we want to evaluate the
polynomial at a point x comma y
well then this is simply the
uh a vector matrix vector product which
we're using the vectors x which is the
uh monomials
of the challenge x of the evaluation
point x and
the vector y which includes which has
the consists of the monomials of
of uh the evaluation point y
so if we want to construct an evaluation
proof
we now have to construct a
proof for this um
for this vector matrix vector product
so for this quadratic form and
the untrusted variant is simply going to
use
an inner pairing product so this is
cheaper instantiated with fgo
to compute x times a
and then we have a prime which is the
result
and that is uh then we can simply use
bullet proofs
or jeeper with incidentally with the
pettis and commitment
to compute a prime times y
and in the end this protocol has
a logarithmic communication but the
interesting thing is that
the prover and verifier
complexity is not linear in
m times n but it's linear in m plus n
and same with the the reference string
size
but because we said m to be roughly
equal
to the square root of d and and the same
then both the prover and the verifier
complexity
are just on the order of square root of
d
and the size of the reference string as
well
so can we do better than this well yeah
with a with the
with our trusted setup protocol
um we can use a structured reference
string
and then in the first step we're going
to use our tip protocol
so this is the the trusted protocol that
i just presented
to compute a prime and then in the
second protocol
we note that a prime is already a kcg
commitment to the univariate polynomial
p of x comma y and
we can simply open this kcg commitment
at the point below y
and now this protocol has again still
has even less communication um
but now it has the verifier complexity
has been reduced to log
n and um or which is equal to which is
of log d
but the important thing is uh with you
might wonder
okay this is a trusted variant and with
a trusted setup
uh in under the same assumptions we
already have
the kzd polynomial commitment which has
even
unless it has constant verifier
complexity
but the key benefits here are that the
prover complexity
is still just m plus n and the verifier
and the the the reference string the
structured updatable
cs is also just m plus n which in the
end gives us
a complexity of square root of d for
um for both of these things
um so this is the key benefit compared
to the kcg polynomial
and there's been really exciting very
recent work
by lee called dory
which builds upon our
polynomial commitment so the commitment
has the same structure and it also uses
uh a different variant of the
inner product arguments it doesn't
actually follow it's a very very key
protocol it doesn't fall into
our generalization but it's
the nice properties are that it has uh
similar the same asymptotics
but it does not rely on a trusted setup
so it also has a logarithmic verifier
but it does not rely on a trusted setup
and it has slightly worse or it has well
it has worse constants than than than
our protocol but
again you know the it's a really really
nice
nice result
so we've implemented and
uh well and when i say we i mean uh
not me personally but uh niren and
done amazing work on this they've
implemented a tip in
in the arc works library family
we call the the library it's open source
and online and you can go
play around with it we call it rip and
um we
uh compared it to
the kcg polynomial commitment and
you can see that especially on on
the uh
on the cs size and the the setup time
here this is really where our uh
protocol
starts to shine so i think um
what did i say earlier it's uh for for
this point here
degree 2 to the 26 or well this is the
last point actually
you have something like uh three
gigabytes
versus uh only a few megabytes
and also the the opening time or
evaluation time
um is grows only a square root of d
and this shows up in the concrete
numbers and the verifying
the verification time and the opening
size is larger
but it remains sort of
reasonable for all of the values that
we've tested
and i very quickly want to also talk
about the
snark aggregation section i think well
uh so this was the
wrap up in a few minutes okay i'll
do this in one minute so
i'll i'll actually skip over the
protocol so but
what we're able to do is we're able to
build a protocol
using again these inner products so that
our tip were called to aggregate
n uh gros16 snarks
and um you can
so the the key benefits of this protocol
are
that the aggregator only does 10
n pairings so um
the the aggregator does not have to rely
on
expensive mp reductions in order to
to do the snark aggregation and
here this is the the one slide i wanted
to show
is that here we compare our approach
with
sexy which was a one-level recursion
protocol and you can see that at
64 proofs i think we're
[Music]
so the the key thing to look up is here
is the
aggregation time so at 64 proofs i think
this is a gap of
this is 900 times uh 900 x speed up
and after that uh the the zextra runs
out of memory
and we can you know continue our
protocol
without uh sort of any of the issues
so it's it's about yeah like 900 to 1000
times
faster and can be run on about a
thousand times
greater instances so um
yeah thank you very much and you can
find the paper online
thank you benedict uh right on time
perfect thank you so much
are there any questions for benedict
um do you have one
hello it's patrick here um benedict you
mentioned in your talk that
applying hma transformed to uh basically
these
recursive arguments will result in
superpolynomial
extractors and i was wondering to which
extractor do you refer to is it the one
from the paper in 2016 by
butter leal or is it the corrected
version that
appeared a bit later by um
del pino zeiler and ubashevsky
uh so my
my um uh my understanding is so this is
the
the kind of the the full core
way to transform or to to show that
a fierce amir protocol is is secure in
the random oracle
is that basically if you if you're well
for
for either of these extractors you you
build a
um for every round
where you need to rewind the prover um
so so the way that the extractor works
and i'm
not a and this is these are all the
interactive so i think there's been
multiple security proofs but
um all the interactive security proofs
that i've seen
the uh interactive uh extraction it
really
relies on rewinding so you have to
rewind the prover to
um for every round to get him to respond
on
different challenges and um
this is if in the if i do the
fiat mia transform and i have a um
an adversary that does is allowed to do
t random oracle
queries i think the only way that we
really know how to do
this rewinding is in every round
you pay a factor of t and then it
multiplies across the rounds so this is
where that you get the
t log t to the number of rounds
um factorium and
this is uh this turns out to be super
polynomial in the security paragraph
so i i don't know the exact answer to
your question but i think it applies to
so as far as i know i think the um
we just don't know i mean maybe there's
a way to prove
uh i mean i think this is a great open
question
but um i haven't seen sort of a way to
do the non-interactive proof in a
non-idealized model
um okay so um maybe i can be a bit more
precise here
so um the way um
the way it's proven in 2016 paper is
that
so like you mentioned at each recursion
step you necessarily
need to get like five different distinct
pairwise distinct challenge values i
guess at each recursion desk so you end
up with a tree
and the question is how do you build
this tree and
in the 16 version uh there was an issue
because basically
um the the the extractor would uh
fix a value at one step of the protocol
continue
and then uh until and then it would end
up let's say in the middle of the tree
and then we'll have to
generate different values but he wasn't
sure whether the path to the tree up to
there
was one that would lead to actually a
high probability or not
so basically the correction was to from
the beginning of the three and
before appending a newly a new node
let's try to estimate whether
the node that we just that we just
picked was a good one
and by doing so i mean one can prove
that the extractor there runs in
polynomial time but then of course this
is
in the interactive version what you're
mentioning is okay if i do hatchimir
then um there would be a nested
rewinding that's what you're saying but
in the sense
i have a feeling that this corrected
version already sort of takes care of
this nesting
i'm not entirely um
sure right so you're right i mean it's
it's all about the fork and hammer right
like
where it's uh you know we basically need
to get a
log round forking lemma um
in the uh yeah in
for the non-interactive uh variant and
um yeah i i would be very
interested i i don't actually
know the answer but um
[Music]
maybe it takes care of that but i i
haven't seen that and
i'm not sure it's just my intuition that
it should but okay but
we can have this exchange via emails
afterwards if you want
yeah yeah i would be very interested in
that um
so basically yeah this correction there
was a corrected version afterwards and
perhaps you can have a look at that and
also there is a paper at tcc uh
i think in 2019 or 20 which tries to
know
the the version of the 2016 paper
yeah so so i think stephanie this is the
paper by stefano tesara so this deals
with the fact that
um the 2016 [ __ ] lima is or
it mainly deals i think with the fact
that it's an expected time
um
analysis so that the extractor succeeds
in in producing this this tree of
transcript
uh in expected polynomial time but now
then we don't really have a worst case
noun and
um stephanos paper i think looks very
carefully at at that and gives concrete
um concrete security bounds
um and but i i still don't
think this solves the the uh
the non-interactive um problem
is for that for the 16 version okay okay
yeah yeah i would be i mean i would be
really interested in to see it but
uh yeah okay thank you
so there is another paper uh
from uh in university of washington
right the one by ashraejit and
stefano that does look good i didn't
interact so i think they do
something at least i mean i think they
do something
similar to us i think just a lot more
general and looking at more general i
think the the the play between
fiatumia and the algebraic group model
um well we focus on you know kind of our
one protocol family
um so i think that is you know that is
uh
i think similar very similar ideas there
more questions for them
okay wonderful so if there aren't any
more questions uh then thanks again
benedict for being uh
a great talk and uh
so we have another morning talk in uh
five minutes so yeah i suggest
when we take a break walk around a bit
and we're gonna resume in a
little over five minutes with jonathan
stock